bringing the latest technology to your
home
the Swiper port on Sky News is sponsored
by currents PCWorld
and green this is swipe coming up on
this week's show northern powerhouse the
success of Yorkshire games industry
I look at the build-it-yourself codable
and wearable gadget for kids and we
returned to the empire of aisles in our
games review welcome to swipe we're at a
school in East London this week because
I'm about to join a group of under 12s
learning to code with a toy you can wear
but before then we're gonna head to
Yorkshire where Chris has been finding
out how the region's games industry has
been making a mark on the global scene
the Broken Sword series is one of the
world's most well known adventure game
franchises it was made by york-based
studio revolution software co-founded by
Charles Cecil in 1919
our mission was very much to write
narrative based games adventure games
and so all the Broken Sword games have
always had a very rich historical
background based on authentic authentic
history which I get passionate about and
I try and convey why it's so rich and
why it's so exciting in our in our
stories it's one of the many local
success stories being celebrated at the
first ever Yorkshire Games Festival the
event in Bradford has been launched to
pay tribute to the region's games
industry the Yorkshire region is
absolutely thriving for games production
in fact 9% of the UK games industry is
based in Yorkshire and that's growing
we've got companies in this region that
are very very well established Yorkshire
and the Humber boasts more than 140
active game studios many of which are
internationally acclaimed other iconic
titles developed in the region include
the worms franchise and the latest
installment of LittleBigPlanet but it's
not all about past success here
Sheffield Hallam University has its own
commercial studio where students get
real-world experience of making and
publishing their own games if you go
back in 20 30 years it didn't require as
much technical knowledge to make a game
as it does now there's an awful lot the
students are expected to know so the
still we need to do was set up exactly
for the purpose of helping students to
bring games to market particularly on
platforms like PlayStation Works it's
not actually easy to do that if you
haven't got the view of the commercial a
necessity
so we in the studio we've been able to
work with Sony to actually create and
release our own games on the PlayStation
Network so what advice does an industry
veteran have for budding games designers
please please please be original don't
just say it's the first-person shooter
but come up with something particularly
fuel to write your own games that feels
really innovative that feels different
and you know you look at a game say like
Angry Birds which has been an absolute
phenomenon from Rovio Rovio had written
52 games which had all failed before
they came up with Angry Birds the rise
of mobile gaming is helping the region
nearly 2/3 of the studios here are
publishing titles for that platform
London and the south is still the
dominant force when it comes to the UK's
games industry but with Yorkshire seeing
a 60% growth in the number of studios
over the past five years there's lots of
positivity about the future Chris
Creegan Sky News stay with us still to
come I'll be learning how to use this
it's a wearable for children that
responds to movements that's coming
right up after a roundup of this week's
tech news Donald Trump's election wing
led to a surge in the price of Bitcoin
investors flocked to the digital
currency following uncertainty in the
stock market which drove up its value by
around three percent a robot has set a
new Rubik's Cube record the sub-1
reloaded solve the puzzle in just 637
milliseconds compare that to the current
human record of 4.7 for seconds
the robots creators hope the technology
will help self-driving cars detect and
respond to obstacles quickly the first
Hyperloop transport system looks set to
be built in Dubai the technology which
is the brainchild of Tesla founder Elon
Musk will use vacuum-sealed pods and
electric propulsion the plan is to cut
the 90 mile journey from Dubai to Abu
Dhabi to just 12 minutes and a world war
two veteran has used virtual reality to
return to the town he helped liberate
from the Nazis 91 year-old Frank Nico we
visited the French town of our Monti air
where he got to hear from Reza
and received a medal from the town's
mayor
we're eagle death stick around for our
games review but first right time now to
find out how this works its creator has
come down to the school to talk to us
about it today but some of the kids are
having a go to this is Bethany hello
everyone very quiet
I noticed but it's also us about this so
this is the move our kit it's the latest
toy that we've created which is a
collection of toys that kids have to
make and code themselves so it can I
come and come and chat to you guys well
Bethany explains the process as well so
straight out of the box you can see that
you're presented with a circuit board a
case and some accessories and so
essentially kids can it's an assemble
and create their own wearable so they
put the pieces together and they put it
in the case and then they're able to
turn it on and straight out of the box
it unleashes light so one of you guys
been doing with although I don't have
been made it for that did you Bethany we
made we made it for use of anything so
if a parent bought this for their child
does the parent have to know how to code
no we don't expect parents or kids to
have any prior experience with coding or
with technology and what do you say to
people who reckon the kids coding toy
market is getting a little bit
overcrowded right now the more
opportunities we give kids to actually
be engaged and producing the tech the
better and we have a really interesting
stat that we share sixty-five percent of
kids in primary school their jobs do not
exist yet so they're gonna have to
invent their jobs and programming is
gonna be one of those skills that they
need but they need to have confidence or
on tech and what they can do with it
what about the parts will they become
obsolete really quickly there's super a
universal
component so LEDs motion sensor
accelerometer which is in every single
mobile device and a compass so they're
not about obsolete parts they're about
Universal parts that can help kids
invent with tech and you're gonna make
one for adults because I could do with a
toy teach me how to go we've had lots of
parents in their testing sessions
inventor funny games with whisking eggs
and there were a few drinking games
which were quite funny and so I think
there is an opportunity for parents to
be a part of the journey now time for
this week's games Ruby and we're
stepping into the shoes of a
supernatural assassin here's Luci the
big release this week is Dishonored 2 so
dishonored came out in 2012 and it was a
game that was heavily inspired by
classic stealth titles like thief and it
had this incredible art style and now
the sequel is set 15 years after the
original game and you can play as the
protagonist from the first game so you
could play as Corvo attano the Empress's
bodyguard / assassin or you can play as
emily kaldwin who is the little girl
from the first game it's a brand new
sort of world so in the first game you
were in the city of dunwall which was
heavily inspired by Edinburgh Victorian
London now we're going to Carnac er
which is by the sea it's a lot more
colorful and yet there's a load of ways
you can get around it you can leap over
buildings you can walk in the shadows
and you can assassinate your targets so
dishonored has a really great method of
playing so you get these sort of pseudo
magical powers so you can as Emily you
can chain enemies together so if you
kill one of them they all have the same
fate so you'll kill all of them and the
great thing about Dishonored is that
these powers link together in some ways
that you can't really predict and half
the fun of the game is just going
through and mixing up the powers to take
out targets
always eager flight is a PlayStation VR
game from Ubisoft so in that Ubisoft
Assassin's Creed games you know the the
Eagle is a big strong emblem on the teef
that they use and so in Eagle flight you
play as an eagle so you've got the
PlayStation VR headset on and you're
looking through the eyes of an eagle and
it takes place in a dilapidated city of
Paris so nature's taken over again and
there's also a really cool multiplayer
aspect of it so it's basically a capture
the flag mode so you and your team are
against another team of Eagles and you
have to sort of capture the flag and get
it back to your base but you can also
sort of screech at the enemy team which
is sort of like an attack mode it's
quite interesting it's a sort of a new
take on VR it's um
interesting to see if it takes off but
it's a cool experience
Robinson the journey is another VR game
it's made by Crytek who are very famous
for making the Far Cry games crisis and
of course the CryEngine which is a very
powerful very beautiful looking engine
so they've put that in their brand new
game Robinson the journey to create this
sort of tropical world that you can
explore and for 360
it's basically Robinson Crusoe but with
dinosaurs and with artificial
intelligence so you have like a robot
friend and also a little pet dinosaur
which is quite cool it's a pretty much
the classic tale of Robinson Crusoe you
play as a young boy called Robin your
ship crash lands on this planet and
you're sort of left to explore and try
and survive and it's in VR so it's a
very immersive experience you walk
around you solve puzzles and it's just
another very cool use of VR and now the
PlayStation VR is out if something that
people should be trying
well I'll say for this week but if you
enjoyed the show you can watch any of
our swipe episodes in our YouTube
playlist just type in song be back next
week hope you can join us then bye bye
bringing the latest technology to your
home
the swipe report on Sky News is
sponsored by Korea's PC world and ring